well first of all i saw the photo and
the 14 year old in me was like oh
yeah
but you know it's a it's a funny it's a
funny photo and he's trying to be funny
but um so it worked on all levels but i
when i saw it he sent it to me from work
and i said
can i please have that underwear please
i never asked for anything so anyway i
do have it i'm wearing it right now
oh okay
there was something about the image that
sparked like my you know that little
teenage yep that's it
yeah a lot of debate about the platinum
look but on that yeah yeah no yeah
people do know he's not playing a real
person right now he's playing uh yeah a
fake person so yeah you know
probably the most excited person here
about this movie though is jerry okay i
believe that yeah
jerry o'connell has to
embrace the look
oh my gosh okay not quite barry
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if things don't work out with ryrie uh
maybe
[Laughter]
oh my word
all right are those underwears
are those these are mine see i know
they're mine because they say my name
[Applause]
i think there's a sequel in the works
right
you are coming through the whole show
no you didn't you you didn't you didn't
go google dog at 14 for for this for
this jerry don't forget no i did not no
just can't right yeah
by the way this is where it gets weird
now yeah
okay wait you know what i feel like i
feel like my man has started a real
renaissance like a cannasconce
this is like
i see i see what's going on
like spawned a thousand memes right but
you have a favorite that you uh yeah
there was a meme i really liked um do
you guys have it oh there it is okay so
i saw that someone sent that to me and i
was like hmm
so where's my choice right i said okay
well i definitely want to spend my
nights with the gray man and then spend
my days with ken
[Applause]
that's a fun
that's a party because ken is fun and
the green man you know
[Music]
you